So I wanted to talk today
about investment banking, uh,
which is, uh, a subject of
some interest around here.
Um, but first, I, I, uh,
I thought I would, uh,
there's been so much news.
I wanted to just briefly comment about
what's going on in the world today with
our, um, financial crisis. Uh,
notably I think that this is the,
uh,
it could be the biggest financial
crisis since the great depression. Uh,
and,
uh,
as evidence of that we're seeing a lot of
talk about what changes should be made.
And I think it reminds me of the very
basic fact that we live in a financial
world that was created in the
wake of the Great Depression.
Uh,
so many of our financial institutions
were created in the 1930s,
uh, because that was a time when
everything was being shaken up. And,
uh, it was a time when people were
willing to consider it something really
different.
Uh,
if you just look at back where various
of our institutions when they were
created,
it's most likely to be in the 1930s.
Uh,
we are not yet at such a crossroads.
The financial situation is not
as bad as it was in the 1930s,
but it's getting bad. And as a
result, we're starting to see,
um, proposals for big change.
Notably, uh, on Monday,
the Treasury Department Under
Secretary Henry Paulson, uh,
announced a proposal for fundamental
change in our financial markets.
Uh,
and this proposal if implemented,
might be the biggest change
since the great depression.
Uh, however, uh,
the news are calling it dead on arrival.
Uh,
it's unlikely that the Paulson
proposal will be implemented,
uh,
partly because it's,
it's being proposed by the
Republican administration,
but not just Republican eight,
just an administration that's coming
to an end and we're having an election.
So this,
uh,
Paulson proposal probably has very
little chance of being implemented as is,
but it's puts,
it's put in a to change the discussion.
Uh, and it's, it's going to
be talked about a lot and I,
I suppose it will influence what happens
that the interesting thing is that the
next president of the United States will
likely have a mandate for big changes.
Uh,
so maybe it's just as well that for Bozi
and Al are slow to do a second edition
of their book because if
they got it out this year,
it would be a bad year to get it out
because everything is changing. Uh,
I studied the Paulson proposal
carefully since I'm writing,
I'm writing a New York Times column
about it, which will appear Sunday. Uh,
and reading the various
commentaries about the proposal. Uh,
I had the impression that not many of
them are very thinking very deeply about
it. They're typically, they'd like
to talk about the politics of it,
uh, and this thing that it's
dead on arrival or it's, uh,
someone said it's an
amateur amateurish proposal.
All the groups that stand a win or lose
from it are all figuring out what it
does to them and they're taking
their positions out of self interest.
So I wanted to write
something that was more, um,
perspicacious if I could manage that.
Um,
the interesting thing is actually we,
everyone calls it the pulse and proposal,
but it was apparently mostly written
by a young man who was in his early
thirties. You may not consider that
young, but I think that as young,
he could have taken this course from me
10 years. Actually, he didn't go to Yale.
I looked it up. He went to American
University, both undergraduate and is,
his name is David nascent,
uh, undergraduate.
And then he got a law degree
at American University. Uh,
and then he just went to work for
the government. As far as I know,
he doesn't publish, uh,
is not in the newspaper,
but he's gotten the ear of the treasury
secretary and they spent many weekends
together figuring out what should
be done about the, uh, system. Uh,
and they wrote up a proposal, uh, which I,
I like many aspects of it actually a,
it's an interesting proposal.
Uh, but, uh,
but it's not so much what's in the
proposal as it is that this is a time, uh,
for reconsideration.
Um,
w the w one interesting thing that they
proposed is that we should have what
they call objectives based regulation
of, all right. I can find a piece of
charge. So, uh,
so okay.
So we have, uh, this is David Mason
and Henry Paulson,
although it's not signed by them,
it's signed by the treasury.
Uh,
so the treasury,
it's called a blueprint,
a blueprint for reform of our
financial regulation. Uh, and, um,
it's, it's built around, uh,
what they call objectives
regulation.
That means that,
uh,
the different regulators should
each have their own objective.
And so they have a three part proposal.
There'd be a market stability regulator,
uh,
which would,
make sure that the markets
don't freeze up on us.
We don't have the systemic crisis.
There'd be a prudential
financial regulator,
and then three, there would be
a business conduct regulator.
So that's the, uh, the main part of the
proposal. And so what they're doing is
emphasizing the different,
uh,
objectives of,
of regulators.
Market stability is going to be the Fed.
Uh, but, uh, but it's not just
banking. They want it to be, uh,
the feds role would be broadened so
that it's not just a banking regulator,
it's the whole financial system.
It's supposed to be maintaining
the stability of the system.
Uh,
and then the prudential
financial regulator is, uh,
supposed to regulate, uh,
it's supposed to a mat.
Uh, I, uh,
protecting the u s interest in various
institutions that are guaranteed by the
government, such as, uh, banks
that are federally insured,
uh, are, uh, uh,
enterprises that have government
guarantees are apparent,
government guarantees like
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
And then the business conduct
regulator is supposed to regulate.
Uh,
uh,
well, when I saw it was, it was,
it would be aimed at consumer protection
okay.
That it would, um, make sure
that businesses are, uh,
are protecting individuals.
Uh,
so I found this,
uh,
interesting because it calls to mind
some of the problems we had with the
subprime crisis.
One very important problem was in the u
s we have regulation divided up in crazy
are archaic ways. Different agencies
were formed at different times,
and they have specific
missions. Uh, and for example,
we have the office of the Office
of the comptroller of the currency.
The OCC was founded in
1863 to national banks,
but it only supervises national banks.
Well,
why not state chartered banks or why
not credit unions or other things?
Um, well it's just an
accident of history. So, um,
what, um, uh,
what these people are proposing is
that we merge various agencies so that,
uh,
and,
and define new agencies of the government
that are separated by these different
objectives. Uh, so an
objective defines an, uh,
an agency or regulatory agency.
Uh,
so, uh, so what, uh,
they want to do is merge
the SI c and the ots merger.
That's one of the proposal, but I
wonder why they don't carry it further,
but that that's,
that's the thing they emphasized.
The OCC is office of the comptroller of
the currency regulates national banks.
The Ot ots is the office
of thrift supervision.
It regulates savings banks.
So we put the two together.
That sounds sensible. I guess.
Why are they separate? Um,
and various other things that
they talked about had that for,
they weren't to merge,
uh,
the Securities and Exchange Commission
and the Commodity Futures Trading
Commission.
All right.
The Securities and Exchange Commission
is the principle government regulator for
securities. They make sure that everything
is on the level and working right.
They pretend they help prevent fraud,
misrepresentation,
manipulation of information
in stocks and bonds.
The CFTC is the commodity futures
trading commission and it regulates our
futures markets.
Um,
there has been over the years a lot of
turf battles between the SEC and the CFTC
because it's sometimes unclear whether
something is a security or a future.
For example, when they started
trading stock index futures, these,
both these agencies thought it was in
their turf because it involved both stock
indexes and futures.
Anyway,
false in is proposing merging these,
uh,
that makes sense. And it seems like, uh,
getting rid of some of this division of
regulatory agencies is very beneficial.
Uh, and it, the division is
what hampered regulators from,
from dealing with the
financial subprime crisis.
So people knew that a lot of bad loans
were being made or loans were being made
to people who couldn't be getting them
low income people were being given
adjustable rate mortgages with very low
starter rates called teaser rates that
would be raised in the future.
And they were given them with in such
a way that after the rates were raised,
they likely couldn't afford to pay the
mortgage anymore or they'd be under great
stress and trying to do so.
So a family that bought a house,
low income family buys a house,
they can barely afford it.
Then the rates go up on them.
The parents would have to take out
second jobs to try to, you know,
they're just going to, they're just
going to go bankrupt when that happens.
So it was a,
in some cases unethical and
it was plainly a problem,
and yet the regulatory agencies
in the U s weren't stopping it.
Uh,
another reason why the regulatory agencies
weren't stopping these problems was
because they often saw their
mission in different terms.
So when I gave a talk at the occ in 2005,
I was asking them about,
why aren't you policing these mortgages?
And their first answer was,
well, you have to remember,
we were set up in Abe Lincoln's Day
to manage the national banks. Uh,
we're, that's our mission. W W W I,
I may be overstating their answer,
but I got that flavor from them that you
want us to go out and protect consumers.
Well, of course that's a nice mission,
but that's not our mandate. So,
uh, uh, so, uh,
I think that what Paulson and nascent
want to do is to create a separate
business conduct agency that is
aimed at consumer protection.
And so it would be working parallel
with these other agencies too, uh, too.
But their job would be to
represent the consumer.
And that sounds like a good idea to me.
Um,
the thing I stressed in my column
was the market stability regulator,
which is the Fed.
What they want to do is expand the
actions of the feds that they're not just,
you can describe the Federal
Reserve or any central bank.
Traditionally as a banker's bank, remember
I told you the story of how the first,
the Bank of England was the first central
bank and it made banks keep deposits
at the Bank of England.
So in other words,
the banks were like customers
of the Bank of England.
They had to keep deposits there.
And the Bank of England watched them
to make sure that they were behaving
responsibly and had authority
over them because it, um,
it had a market power.
Well the Fed is like that now.
Um,
but what,
uh,
Paulson and Mason wanted to do is make
it more than a banker's bank didn't want
it to be a bank for the
whole financial system.
And that's what's already
happening. Uh, in fact,
it's just happening rapidly as we
speak. I mean, in this last month,
things have changed.
The Fed has never given loans to anyone
other than a depository institution that
is a bank until last month. And
except they did. So on the depression,
there was this long gap in the 1930s,
the Fed was making loans to private
companies that were not banks.
And then they stopped doing that until
last month. Uh, and they created the,
I mentioned that last time,
that term securities lending facility
and the primary dealers credit facility,
which are lending outside
the banking system. And so,
uh,
what Paulson wants to do is make that
official that the Fed is no longer just a
central bank.
It's a market stability regulator.
This is going to be very controversial,
but I think it's a good thing to raise,
uh, in my opinion. Uh,
this is the trend anyway, and I
think we're going that way. Uh,
the problem is that in a
modern financial economy,
we have so much instability,
which is already built into the system
that, uh, that, uh, we have to,
we rely on something like a central
bank, uh, to do things that,
uh,
that helps stabilize markets.
Uh, and so
I think that we're probably
going that way anyway.
And I think that in the next
presidential administration,
we'll see an expansion of the role,
uh, of the Fed. Uh,
I wish the Fed had behave better
in the recent crisis in a sense.
They didn't seem to recognize the bubbles
that we had in the stock market in the
90s and the housing market
and the two thousands.
And if there are market
stability regulator,
you'd hope that they could
do a better job. Uh, but,
uh, there what we have, and I think
that, that we should probably, uh,
uh, give them the
authority to do that job.
And I think that's what we need to do.
So I was generally positive about their,
the treasury proposal,
but, um, another thing
that they want to do,
which has been talked about for some time.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah. So he asked why,
why did the news media,
I think that the crisis is
already over. Uh, and secondly,
why do they think we can prevent,
right. Is that, I'm paraphrasing. Uh,
I don't know if the news media are
concluding anything, but you do see,
we have seen over recent
years we've seen a lot of, um,
uh, suggestions that the turning
point is just around the corner.
And so,
uh,
in the news media report that I think
there's a bias towards optimism, uh,
buy in among business economists
generally are business people in general.
You know,
it's not considered good form to say,
I think we're about to have the crisis
of confidence and the whole house of
cards is going to collapse.
So it's also not a, you know,
if generally not in a business
person's interest to suggest that.
So we're all instinctively trying
to promote each other's confidence.
And that's what business people do. They
carry it a little further than that. Uh,
I was, uh, I was asked to be on, uh, uh,
it could and Kramer I could
load and company show. Um,
uh, I guess it was two nights
ago I turned them down,
but they wanted to put me on opposite the,
the CEO of Coldwell banker.
Uh,
and uh, who is, uh, who is claiming
that the crisis is just about to end.
So I did a little research.
I would be thinking,
I have still might go on
the show, but, uh, I, um,
I looked up a CEO of Coldwell banker,
but I found that there was another CEO,
this is a broker,
a real estate brokers for,
there was another CEO a year ago who was
on TV just exactly a year ago saying,
I think this is the best time ever,
or the best time in at least 10 years
to buy a house. And he said, uh,
the, uh, inventory is high. Uh,
the market is bottoming out.
Uh, and so, uh, he was
spectacularly wrong,
but I notice he's also no longer CEO.
So these things happen.
So, uh, there is a general
bias. On the other hand,
I have to respect these people that
usually financial crises and okay,
there's, there, there are repeated
scares and usually it's all right.
Like we had a big scare in 1998,
uh,
it started with the Asian financial
crisis and then it spread to Russia and
there was this terrible
collapse in Russia in 1,998, uh,
when the government couldn't pay its
debts and then that spread to the u s and
people were very fearful.
But the Fed under Alan Greenspan was
very quick to respond and the whole thing
didn't turn out to be anything so bad.
The,
the Fed again did like what it's doing
now at rescued a company called long term
capital management. Uh, but your,
your question about whether we can prevent
this kind of thing in the future is a
deep question.
And I think that the problem is that
our financial markets are inherently
somewhat unstable.
When we start thinking up really important
new ways of doing financial business,
they start to grow and they get huge, get
bigger and bigger before you know, it,
it, it's amazing how things can suddenly
grow and then nobody understands them.
So there's a vulnerability.
I was just the got the latest number.
Do you know how much credit default
swaps there are? Outstanding.
According to the bank for
international settlements,
there are now $52
trillion worth of credit.
Default swaps,
outstanding.
$52 trillion with a GDP of the
United States is only 14 trillion.
So how can that be $52 trillion and
these things all I came in in the last 10
years or so. Um, and so I called the
bank and economist at the vis and said,
can you please explain it to me?
Where is this 52 trillion coming from?
Uh, and, uh, I got a note from him
and still trying to figure it all out.
But that's what happens.
The system performs very well
and then it becomes vulnerable.
Nobody understands all of it. So
that's, that's the problem. Uh, and,
uh,
the other side of it though is there was
a recent study that looked at financial
crises and compared countries that have
had financial crises with countries that
haven't.
And the conclusion was that countries
that have experienced financial crises are
generally more successful on average
over the long haul than countries that
haven't. Uh, and so in that sense,
a financial crisis is assign just
that you're moving with the times, uh,
and you know,
you,
you're making a lot of money and so then
things suddenly blow up on you, but hey,
you're, you'll recover and
you'll figure something out.
And then you have moved from there.
Uh, so I don't know that, uh,
Paulson's proposed Parsons proposals.
I kind of like them.
Uh, but I think that they're not enough.
That's why I'm writing a book about this.
I think there's a lot more to be done,
but even if you did
everything that I would do,
we would still have a vulnerability.
The financial crises.
And part of the reason why I'm endorsing
this market stability regulator,
uh,
is that I think that there's no way that
we can just guarantee there's no way we
can set up a system that is both very
effective in allocating resources.
And that is also,
that is also a very stable,
uh, so, you know,
just like when we went to the moon
and we sent people up into space,
one of those space shuttles blew
up. Well that's what happens. Uh,
but most of them made it
all right. So, um, uh,
that's the way it is in, in
finance as well. So anyway,
I'm here to talk today about
investment banking, uh,
which of course is relevant to this is
all part of this general thing. But, uh,
let me,
uh,
I said earlier that investment banking
seems to be a great interest of students
at Yale.
Uh,
that's because they get some
really great jobs there. Uh,
it's a,
uh,
investment banking is a very important
economic institution and its fundamental,
what they do is fundamental to what
happens in our economy. And so, uh,
as a result,
uh,
people who work for them have a chance,
for great economic success.
And I'm not saying you want a job at
an investment bank because it's also a
demanding and difficult. And, uh, I,
I've talked to some of our students who
have been taken jobs at investment banks
and, uh, sometimes I think
they're probably too demanding.
As a young person,
you should be enjoying your youth and
not getting dragged in to some huge
investment bank. And some, there are some
terrible stories. Young people who took,
uh,
who left the college five,
10 years ago and they got
a job at bear Stearns, uh,
and bear Stearns demand.
I'm just making this story up,
but it must be something like this
for somebody demanded 80 hour,
a hundred hour week devotion to the job,
but they kept paying in bear Stearns stock
and the extent the student was making
millions every year, uh,
meanwhile, uh, was, uh,
his youth was going
away. And, uh, now, uh,
this imaginary student
is now 33 years old.
Never had time to marry or
have you started a normal life.
And then the whole thing blows up and all
the various during stock is worth just
about nothing. Um, so that's the kind
of mistake you don't want to make.
Uh, I, I find the
industry very interesting.
You have to form some kind of balance
in your life and not let anyone demand a
hundred hours a week of your
time. Uh, and if they do,
you should sell the stock they give
you as soon as you can diversify.
Uh, but I also like investment
banking because I've created one.
We have, um, uh,
my colleagues and I founded a investment
bank called macro markets. Uh,
and I'm not actually running it.
I'm a coffee.
It's named after a book I
wrote called macro markets. Uh,
and we're not a very
big important bank yet,
but it makes me interested
in the whole field. Uh, uh,
we have only hired one Yale students so
far because we're too tiny a to if there
were not hiring in case
you wonder. Uh, uh,
uh, so yeah, it was a student in this
class that we hired, but again, that's,
that's all history. So, um,
so anyway, uh, what does investment
banking, which is the subject of, uh,
investment banking,
uh,
means the underwriting of securities.
There's a,
that is arranging for the issuance
by corporations of stocks and bonds.
So the, the term bank is
misleading because, uh,
we often use it,
I'm writing over here,
a depository institution,
uh,
is an institution that accepts deposits
and make loans or invest
the money from the deposit.
Do you know what I mean by it depends.
If you go to a savings bank or a savings
and loan or a commercial bank and you
say, I want to open up a checking
account that's a deposit,
or I want to open up a savings
account, that's a deposit. Okay?
The thing about a deposit is you deposit
your money as an individual and there
are millions of people that all deposit,
uh,
in, in a depository
institution. And then, uh,
later on whenever you want, you
can take your money out. Meanwhile,
they invest the deposit
somewhere or another at a
higher interest rate than they
pay on the deposits and
they make the difference.
And that's how they make a profit.
So I often use the word bank to refer.
And so does everyone do
a depository institution.
But if you look at what the law says,
they tend to use the word depository
institution and Investment Bank.
If it's doing our pure investment
banking business is not a depository
institution. So if you go into
an investment bank and say,
I want to open up a deposit,
they'll say you should go next door
to the credit union or something.
We don't do that. Uh, so the
word bank is somewhat misleading.
Uh, on the other hand,
historically, most institutions,
uh, uh, do both. If you
go around the world,
uh,
most banks,
most depository institutions are
also involved in investment banking.
But let me just get right under here.
And investment banking does
underwriting of securities.
Okay.
And what does that mean?
That means they, they,
uh,
arrange for the issuance by
other institutions of securities.
So, for example, if Ford
Motor Company wants to, uh,
issue corporate bonds or they
want to issue new shares,
they would go to an investment bank and
the investment bank, we'd say, okay,
we can underwrite for you, but
we'll do it for you. So, um,
uh,
so a pure investment bank a is
not a depository institution
and it's also a pure
investment bank is not
a broker dealer either.
They're not trading and securities there,
although they would,
they would deal insecurities as a
part of the underwriting process,
but they're not. Uh, you
wouldn't go to an investment,
a pure investment bank either and say,
I want to buy a hundred shares of Ford
Motor Company. Where's your stockbroker?
They wouldn't be dealing with
that. They would, they deal,
their customers are companies. Uh, and uh,
they wouldn't do that either now,
but in many cases, firms do a
mixture of different activities,
one of which is investment banking.
But there's a peculiar, um,
it's a story that refers particularly
do America, United States.
And that is the glass steagall act
of 1933.
Again,
you see everything happened in the 30s.
Uh,
the stock market crash in 1929 cause
tremendous chaos in the financial markets.
And, uh, Carter Glass, uh,
was a senator from Virginia and he,
and I think it's Henry Stegal,
uh,
put together a bill,
which passed congress and was
signed by President Roosevelt. Uh,
that said that, uh, we want to, um,
make a law saying that investment banks,
uh,
cannot be combined with commercial banks
or insurance investment banking had to
be a separate from,
okay,
this was what they said in 1933.
You could not be both a depository
institution and an investment bank.
So they said,
after this act,
every bank has to choose one or the other.
Do you want to be investment bank
or Commercial Bank? So for example,
then JP Morgan in the United States was
founded by a man named James Pierpont
Morgan.
Uh,
and it was one of the biggest
banks in the U S uh, in 1933,
it was told you gotta make a choice.
Uh,
are you an investment bank
or a commercial bank? Uh,
and so JP Morgan made a
choice, a and said, well,
we'll go to be commercial bank.
And so they stopped their
investment banking business, uh,
in 1933 they've since gotten
back into it, but, uh, that,
that's the, but for a long
time they became a commercial
bank. So what happened?
They had a lot of people at JP Morgan
who were doing investment banking, uh,
and they, um, uh,
they, uh, uh,
were upset because Davey Morgan
was shutting them down. So, uh,
there was a Mr. Stanley, I forget
his first name now, uh, who has,
I've mentioned him cause he
was a Yale graduate and, uh,
he got the guys together from JP
Morgan who did investment banking.
Um, and JP Morgan was dead
already, but, uh, his son,
the young Morgan, uh, and
he created Morgan Stanley.
Okay.
I have the suspicion that Mr. Stanley put,
uh,
the son of JP Morgan on just
for the prestige of the name.
It sounds a lot better.
Right. Morgan Stanley, uh,
and so this became an investment bank.
Okay.
And now JP Morgan and
Morgan Stanley are over 70,
75 years later.
Our competitors.
[inaudible]
so, uh, so that, that is the
important history of glass.
Steagall um, but the problem
is that as the years went on,
uh,
in the U s we had a division between
investment banking and commercial banking,
but in Europe, uh, and in
other places of the world,
their banks were under no such restriction
is there was a lot of complaints that
are laws in the U s we're
handicapping the, uh, u s banks.
Uh, and, uh, so, uh,
finally glass steagall was repealed,
uh, and, uh,
that didn't happen until 1999.
So we have the gram,
oops Leach Bliley if I'm the AF spelling
this right act of 1999 which repealed,
uh, glass steagall. Uh,
and so that led then to a whole
wave of mergers of investment banks.
Uh, so JP Morgan and Morgan Stanley
could presumably have merged,
but they didn't, uh, they become
too much competitors. Uh, and,
and, uh, they, they just developed
their own, uh, they just,
uh, internally adopted more broad
a definition of their business.
Um, so, uh,
but there's lots of mergers that
we can talk about that came, uh,
either sometimes they
occur just before 1999.
Uh, but, um,
uh, which, uh, uh,
uh, so for example, um,
travelers,
and this is the, the new, uh,
Gramm Leach bill also allowed insurance
companies to merge with commercial bank.
So travelers insurance,
uh,
and Citi Group marriaged,
in 1998.
I know that's before the bill.
That was as the bill was just
about to happen. Um, and then, uh,
JP Morgan
and chase a merged in,
um,
how 2000, uh, and then,
uh, UBS, uh, and, um, uh,
Paine Webber,
um, merged in 2000, um, and, uh,
Credit Suisse,
a Swiss bank
and Donaldson,
Lufkin and Jenrette.
Yeah.
Donaldson was the dean of our
business school here at Som,
but that merger occurred in 2000.
So,
uh,
so there's some examples. So now we're,
we're seeing a movement back toward a,
so that a bank has an investment
banking business within it,
but it's not just an investment
back. Uh, and so, uh,
sometimes hard to define
what something he has.
There's been a lot of news just in
the last year or even more recently,
like yesterday, or like tomorrow, this
morning's paper about an investment banks,
because under the
current financial crisis,
uh, they are buckling there. A
lot of them are in trouble. Uh,
and that's why it's big news.
Uh,
so I give you some
examples. Um, I mentioned,
I mentioned bear Stearns. Um, so, uh,
bear Sterns,
uh,
was founded in 1923 by,
uh, Joseph Bear and Robert Stern's. Uh,
I just try to find something out about
them and they don't seem to be very well
known. I couldn't tell you, but not
on the web. There's no bear stern.
There's no Joseph Bear is
my work club on the web,
but whatever they set up was
really big for awhile. So, uh,
I'm gonna say from 1923
to 2008 when it went bust,
so it lasted a 85 years.
Uh,
so, uh, it's, uh,
it has investment banking business,
but it also has private equity
business and private banking. Uh,
and, uh, it started to get in
trouble during the current, in fact,
it was maybe the first a US investment
bank to get in trouble in the current
financial crisis because
it was in, um, uh,
June of 2007,
uh, they had, uh, some of
their funds collapsed. They,
they had funds that we're investing
in subprime mortgages. Uh,
and this is a sign of something wrong.
The names of these funds were,
uh,
the bear Stearns high grade
structured credit fund.
You have to say high grade,
high grade is supposed to mean and finance
that it's not going to fail on your
right. Well, uh, and they had, uh,
they had another one called the bear
Stearns high grade structured structured
credit enhanced leverage fund.
That sounds a little bit contradictory.
You should,
as a consumer of financial products,
wonder when they put both high grade
and leveraged in the same name. Right?
High grade is supposed to mean safe,
but leverage sounds like the opposite,
doesn't it?
If you leverage means that they borrowed
a lot of money to buy risky subprime
securities.
So if they borrowed 80% of the money,
the security is only half to lose 20%
of the value for you to be wiped out.
Right? So that shouldn't be high
grade if it's so leveraged. So anyway,
these two funds were
wiped out. Uh, and uh,
bear Stearns had to
give, uh, uh, deal, uh,
three point $2 billion. That
was last summer, but they,
the news kept getting worse and worse.
Apparently bears had invested a
lot in securities that were, uh,
unstable.
And so it finally became where rumors
started developing that bear was,
it was really rumors that killed there.
The rumors started going,
now you know, bear is in trouble.
And so there you're going to be,
they're going to be in
bankrupt before long.
This is exactly the market stability
problem that Paulson is talking about.
Once the rumors get started,
everybody is saying, don't,
don't do anything with bear.
Don't, don't lend them any money.
Don't just stay away from them.
Even young people who are getting jobs
and they were right to right to think
this,
don't even take a job with them because
you're going to be on the street again
shortly. So it's that kind of
rumor that kills bear Stearns.
Uh, and so they couldn't, they
couldn't pay their bills and, and they,
they were finding it difficult to sell
their assets to come up with money. Uh,
and so,
uh,
the Fed decided to bail them out.
This was a huge fed bailout.
Well, they didn't want,
uh,
the Fed didn't want to
bail out the stockholders.
They didn't want to just give money to
people who didn't invest because the
firms are supposed to be allowed to fail.
So what the Fed did is it gave a line
of credit to JP Morgan and non-recourse
line of credit to buy bear Stearns.
And what it amounted to was that
the Fed would take a troubled,
a securities that bear
Stearns couldn't sell.
It would take that as collateral for
eight $29 billion loan to JP Morgan,
uh, under the condition that JP
Morgan would buy bear Stearns.
And it was supposed to be at $2 a share.
Uh,
and so that left the total value of bear
Stearns at a little over 200 million,
which is pretty tiny compared
to what they were worth. Um,
which was in the tens of billions
short while ago. Uh, but the,
the Fed didn't want a
disorderly collapse. So, uh,
so it was a,
uh,
a $29 billion loan to JP Morgan.
This is highly controversial
these days because, uh,
uh,
the Fed isn't normally
doing this sort of thing.
Why would it be lending money to JP
Morgan to buy another company? You know,
you say, how is that benefiting the,
the average person in this country?
Uh, but it does benefit them
because if they didn't do this,
bear Stearns would have dumped
its assets on the mock market. Uh,
it would go down in flames. Uh,
lots of its debts would become, uh,
lots of people who had, uh, you know,
accounts with bear Stearns and find
that their accounts were destroyed. Uh,
and, uh, and then what would it do?
It might lead to contagion
to other financial institute.
People would say, well,
it happened to bear who's next?
And so there'd be this huge pulling back.
So the Fed decided to bail,
bail them out.
And that's what they did.
Now it's not clear that it's over.
If you read this morning's paper,
Lehman Brothers is another,
uh,
another, uh, investment bank that, uh, uh,
is rumored to be in
trouble. And so, um, it's,
it's got to do something about these
rumors, uh, because it can kill them,
kill them, just the rumors, no one what
we'll want to do anything with them.
So it was in this morning's
paper or yesterday's news
that they have arranged to
raise capital,
uh,
on the, on the markets, uh, and it was not
entirely clear. That means that they're,
they're getting people who are
willing to invest, give them, uh,
invest in the company.
Uh,
and it's a sign of confidence in Lehman
brothers that someone would do that at
this critical time.
Um,
so another story that
came in yesterday was UBS.
I mentioned before it was a Swiss bank,
but it's not Swiss and it's
international. I started out, uh,
as the Union Bank of Switzerland.
That's what it stands for.
Union Bank of Switzerland, which was, uh,
uh,
the result of a merger between
two Swiss banks around 1900.
Uh, but then it had, uh,
I mentioned merged, uh,
with Paine Webber and it's become an
international corporation. So they,
they just call themselves UBS. But
in, in this morning's newspaper,
uh, it said that UBS
announced that it has lost,
um, what was it? The same way?
Remember what the numbers were?
What's that?
They've lost 19 billion.
Yeah.
Right.
So, uh, yeah, so that's
a huge loss. $19 billion.
It's a substantial part
of their market cap,
but they are also announcing that they
are arranging to raise capital as well.
So, uh, the news that these firms
which are rumored to be in trouble,
are managing to raise
capital. Uh, Boyd markets.
Yesterday we had a big upsurge
in the stock market. Uh, it was,
uh,
well yesterday was the first day of the
second quarter and the newspapers were
reporting that it was the biggest,
uh,
upsurge on the mark on the first
day of a new quarter since 1938.
Um, I looked at that with some curiosity
because 1938 was not such a great year
after all who were still on the
depression. Uh, I think, uh,
I have to look up the market didn't do
great after that then. So it doesn't,
this doesn't predict much
one way or the other.
Uh, but, uh, uh,
so anyway, this is where we are
now. It's an interesting situation.
If you are thinking of taking a
job at one of these companies,
you might consider the,
uh,
look out there a situation because
some of these companies could, uh,
follow the way of, of bear Stearns. Um,
at this point, uh, we have
the Fed aggressively landing.
I'm trying to prevent another thing,
but you know,
the Fed is not in the business of making
sure that your career is a success
there in the business of preventing
a systemic failure. So while the Fed,
uh, arranged for an orderly
dissolution of bear Stearns,
it didn't do a whole lot of
good to their employees who,
uh, we'll see what happens to all of them.
I don't know the whole story, but, um, uh,
it's a tumultuous world out there.
It's not a,
it's not like you live in an academic
environment where Yale University has been
in business for over 300 years
and it looks so stable here. Well,
this is a very stable business and these
other businesses are not so stable.
But anyway, I wanted to talk about
the underwriting process and um,
uh, what it's done. So, uh,
I think underwriting of
securities, uh, is, um,
uh,
it's analogous.
The investment banking business is
analogous to the business done by, um,
by ordinary commercial banks in the
sense that it deals with the moral hazard
problem and an asymmetric
information problem.
We were talking about,
uh, about what banks do,
commercial banks. Remember I
was telling the story that, uh,
the big problem with lending to companies
is that it's hard to tell whether they
are really deserving of the loan or not.
And so a commercial banker is someone
who spent lives in a business community
and keeps abreast of everything that's
going on and plays golf with all the
local business people and has a sense,
here's the gossip,
has a sense of who's responsible,
who will pay back alone,
who's got a business that's really going,
who's got a business that's
sick and on the way out. Uh,
and so that's what a bank does.
So everyone else who wants
to invest doesn't know this,
but they put their money in the bank.
And then that's the idea.
So the moral hazard is that moral
hazard that the company, uh, which,
which receives a loan from the
bank would take the money and run.
And the asymmetric information
problem is that, uh,
you as a investor, if you were to
make loans directly to a company,
you would be suffering at a
disadvantage because you know,
less than other people.
Uh,
you don't play golf with these people.
And so you would end up
taking on the worst loans,
loans that would fail. Well, the same
thing applies to underwriting because, uh,
but they do it in a different way.
Instead of a certifying,
instead of creating deposits
at a bank, they, uh,
they underwrite securities and
they are not taking the money.
They're just an intermediary between you,
the public and the issuer of the security.
But it's much the same thing.
It's the reputation of
the, uh, of the bank that,
uh, makes it possible for firms to, uh,
uh,
it makes it possible for firms
to issue securities. So, so the,
the underwriting, uh, is
very important to understand,
uh, because, uh, it's
a process that allows,
uh, issuers of securities to, uh,
take advantage of the
reputation of the underwriters.
The issuer of the security may not be
so well known or not so well understood.
Uh, and so the, the, what happens is, uh,
the underwriter, it's a little w
w what's a good analogy? I was,
I was going to say it's like
a dating service, but that,
I guess dating services don't
do this. Right? They don't call,
they don't testify to the moral
character. They should. It would be nice.
Did they do that? Does anyone do that?
Uh, they probably can't. Right? That's an,
that's an even bigger moral hazard
problem. When you're looking for a spouse,
you have a huge moral hazard problem and
there's nobody there to help you as far
as I know. But at least in the
business world, we have professionals.
So there are matchmakers in a sense,
they're trying to match up, uh,
a company that's issuing securities
to buyers of the securities. Uh, and,
uh,
this is an important reason for a
difference between investment banking and
other aspects of, um,
of finance. Investment.
Bankers will compare it particularly
to traders. Investment bankers
like to cultivate an image of sober
responsibility and good citizenship,
uh, because, uh,
they thrive on their reputation.
And so they,
to be successful as an investment banker,
you have to be so impressive.
Uh,
and so it's such high
character that companies like
Ford and GM will come to you
to represent them in the sale of
their securities. So as a result,
investment bankers tend to be
well dressed. They tend to be, uh,
a patrician in their
appearances and manner. And, uh,
in contrast, traders, uh,
tend to have a vulgar accents.
They shout on the phone and they slam the
phone down, they roll up their sleeves,
they dribble food on their shirt and
maybe putting them down too much.
Uh, so, uh, uh,
I personally think that we have a
strength at Yale because of our patrician
image, uh, in providing
people to work for this field.
So,
uh,
typically investment bankers go
to the symphony on Saturday night.
But beyond that, if you open
up the program at the symphony,
you'll see their name under
platinum sponsor of the program.
And so that's the kind of people that
go into investment bank and they do it
because they have to manage
this underwriting process well.
So what does the underwriting
process? Uh, okay. Well, uh,
what happens is a company that
is thinking of issue, it's at,
say you're at any company, a big
company. It doesn't matter. Uh,
people don't trust big companies even
if had been around a hundred years.
So if Ford Motor Company, it's
been around since when, uh,
something that like around 1900,
but people sure don't trust it anymore
because it's had a history of trouble.
This is not a question just
of morality or the thing.
It's a question of are you
willing to buy their securities?
So they would go to an investment
banker and a, and say we need money.
We'd like to raise it by say,
issuing shares and in our company,
and then, uh, the, uh, they would probably
contact a number of investment banks,
uh, and try to make a
deal. Now that there's, um,
there's two kinds of deals.
There's a bought deal
and a best efforts.
Uh,
the difference is, uh, some investment
bankers will tell the company,
uh, we will, um, we will, you
want to issue these shares?
Fine. Sell them to us, we'll, we'll take
it, we'll give you a price. Of course,
the Investment Bank doesn't
want to hold these shares,
but the investment bank knows the public
well enough to know which shares it can
sell. So in a, in a bought deal,
the investment bank is taking the risk
that they might not be able to sell the
shares at a, at a decent price,
they might lose on it. Uh,
but, uh, also there's a different
kind of offering, uh, which, uh,
uh, maybe the best you could get, it's
called a best efforts are offering.
And here the, uh, investment
banker will not buy the deal,
but it will say that we will use
our best efforts to place this. Uh,
and uh, if you have a minimum price,
uh, we hope we can get above there.
Otherwise the dealer will
fall through. Uh, and so, uh,
the underwriting process, um, uh,
is, uh, it takes the form of, uh, uh,
it's actually very much regulated by
the Securities and Exchange Commission.
So the process, uh, is formalized. Uh,
so, uh, in order to issue securities,
you were talking about
public securities here,
you have to register them with the SEC.
And so the sec then becomes
a partner in a partner, her,
an adversary in your effort
to issue these securities.
So the SEC securities
and Exchange Commission,
all of this might be changed next year.
Who knows?
But this is the way it is
right now. Uh, so, uh, the,
the law says there's a pre filing period.
You have to file with the
SEC, uh, to get, uh, um, your,
your security is effective.
So the idea of I'll say Ford Motor
Company wants to issue new shares,
they go to the investment bank.
A then the investment bank
negotiates with the, uh,
affirm with Ford about what kind of a
securities that wants the issue and what
price is reasonable. Uh,
and during this period,
the sec says there's no talk,
uh,
to the public about the shares, uh, uh,
at during this period,
uh, no talk publicly,
uh,
the fee,
the sec wants to manage the process so
that everything is done appropriately.
Um, at this point during the
pre filing period, the, uh,
the investment bank forms a
syndicate of other end of other
underwriters and they have,
they sign an agreement among underwriters.
Usually one investment bank is not big
enough to handle a big issue and it wants
to get help of other investment banks.
And so they form a syndicate of
underwriters during the pre filing period.
Uh, so, uh, the underwriter,
there's a lead underwriter,
which of Ford Motor Company approached
first and the lead underwriter promised
to take on the issue.
Uh,
but the lead underwriter
doesn't want to do it itself.
And the reason it doesn't want to do it
just itself is that in order to sell an
issue to a broad public,
you have to make use of a broad
network of contacts with the public.
And, uh, no one underwriter,
no one investment bank has,
has them all.
So they formed a syndicate or a
group of investment banks that, um,
that are all participating
in the issue of the security.
Uh, and then they, uh,
then they file and then there's
what's called a cooling off period.
Uh, when the, uh,
security is in registration.
So they file with the Securities
and Exchange Commission, uh, a,
a prospectus for the
preliminary prospectus.
Uh,
this goes to the federal,
to the Securities and Exchange
Commission for approval.
It's not really approval of the
issue, but it's, it's, um, uh,
registration of the issue. Uh, and, uh,
the preliminary prospectus,
uh, is called the red herring.
And, uh, the red herring,
it's lost in history,
why they call it that. There's
different theories about it. It, uh, uh,
herring of course, is a type of fish. Uh,
and the best explanation that I can
get for this name for the preliminary
perspectives is that it was,
uh,
referring to an activity that
hunters used to do with dogs.
Uh, and if I should tell
you this story is about,
I'd like to know why they call it a red
herring. Uh, if you have hunting dogs,
they're supposed to track down a
fox by their sense of smell. Uh,
and so at one pace you can put your
dogs through is to try to try to confuse
them. And they would
take a, a red herring,
which is a very smelly kind of fish,
and they would drag it around
and over the trail of the Fox.
And it's very difficult for dogs to
still smell the fax over that smell.
And so the word red herring became known
as a euphemism for something trying to
distract and confused.
And so it was a joke,
I think it was a joke on Wall Street that
the prospectus is really just there to
try to confuse you. And so they
called it the red herring. Um,
but the preliminary prospectus is now
often printed with red borders on it to
indicate that it's the red herring
and it's only preliminary. Uh,
and so,
uh,
finally it is the Fed evaluates the
prospectus and make sure that it accords
with all regulations. It puts
it up on its website, uh,
at the sec while it's in registration.
Uh,
and again, during the
cooling off period, uh,
firms are allowed to circulate
the preliminary prospectus.
Underwriters are allowed to circulate
the preliminary prospectus with a
potential buyers,
uh,
but they're not supposed to say anything
besides what's in the preliminary
perspectives.
There with are concerned about the SDC
is concerned about people overselling
securities.
Uh,
and so they might point out advantages
of it and not the disadvantages.
The idea of it perspective.
What's in a prospectus.
A prospectus is a document that completely
tells everything about a security.
The whole idea of the sec is that we're
not letting anyone pull the wool over
your eyes. That's why it really
shouldn't be called a red herring.
It's not supposed to deceive you.
It's supposed to pour out
everything about the security.
One thing that's in a prospectus,
a preliminary or final prospectus,
is the company thinks of everything
bad that could ever happen.
If you read prospectuses, they'll
say awful things. If you read them,
care for them. Let's say this company
could lose everything. We could be sued,
we could be going to jail, we might have
done all sorts of, I may be exaggerating,
but uh,
the,
the lawyers put everything imaginable
that could go wrong with US investment in
there. And they do it. Of course,
it's in kind of fine print,
but it's all in there so that
it's disclosed. And so later,
if someone loses money in the
investment and wants to sue them,
then they'll say, well, look,
you know, it's in our prospectus.
And the reason that the SCC doesn't want
them to talk about securities at this
point except to give the prospectus is
so that they can't conceal and hide these
things.
So this is the sec process.
This process says that the underwriters
have to give out the prospectus,
and that's all they can do. They can't
have a separate brochure. They can't,
your broker can't say, well, we're,
we're thinking of a issuing a security,
uh, we've got this perspectives, but I'm
going to send you a brochure instead.
That's easier. Okay. Sec says,
no way because that brochure will be a
sales job and it won't have all of this
in there. So anyway, then
eventually the SCC approves it, uh,
and when it's approved, then
it's effective. Uh, and then, uh,
then the,
uh,
then the underwriters can
start selling the security. Uh,
and at that point, uh, they actually,
it depends on say it's
a best efforts offering.
Then they go around and they try to,
they get a buyers of
the security lined up.
Now you have to understand that there's
a problem issuing a new security
securities that are already
out there and trading.
Everybody knows about them and, and
there's, there's a market for them.
But if you're issuing a new
security, uh, especially there's a,
if it's a company that is issuing shares
for the first time an IPO is an initial
public offering,
an IPO is the first time
that a company issues shares.
So the company is not known to the public.
Uh,
and so it's very hard to get IPOs started
because the company is just not known.
So it's very important that
the underwriters are able
to get attention and get a
market going for the IPO. Um, during the,
uh, cooling off period, uh, uh,
firms also are allowed to place
according to the a sec something called a
tombstone.
And that is an ad in the newspaper,
which we'll announce the, the, uh,
security and what it's very dignified ad
cause it has to meet with the approval
of the Securities and Exchange Commission.
But a tombstone will say,
Ford Motor Company, uh, uh, you know,
1 million shares, uh, offered, uh,
and then it will, um, it will list
all of the underwriting syndicate.
So it'd be a list of all the investment
banks that participated in the issue.
Um, and, uh, so, um,
so that's the basic process
that underwriters go
through to issue securities.
Now part of the thing is I
just wanted to close with,
uh,
basically I think that,
investment banks are very similar
to impresarios in what they do.
They,
but there's what I mean by an Impresario
is someone who manages a singer or a
musician, uh, in concerts, uh, a,
uh, but it's a little different, but, uh,
a underwriter is managing the career of
a security just like somebody else would
be managing the career of a singer.
And they're very concerned
about the reputation and
they're very concerned about
getting sold out performances
all the time. Now,
one thing about Ipos is that,
uh,
they are very hard to get a new security
for a new company going because nobody
knows this company. And so, uh,
the price movements of an
IPO tend to be very volatile.
Uh,
and it's because of the difficulty
in getting IPO is going.
Underwriters have peculiar practices,
uh,
in issuing them.
And it tends to go like this.
Underwriters tend,
and there's been a lot of documentation
of this to underprice Ipos that is,
they sell them for less
than they could get.
Uh,
and that means that Ipos
tend to be oversubscribed.
Okay. Uh, and this sounds strange.
Why would it work this way?
So you, you, you can try this. Call
your broker if you have a broker.
Does anyone here have a
broker? Maybe somebody does,
but think about this anyway.
You could call a broker and fire and say,
Hey,
I hear about IPO as I'd like
to get in on some. Okay.
What do you think the broker will
say? Well, the broker will say,
okay, let me see what I can do for
you. And he doesn't call you back.
And You wonder, well, why does this
person not want my business? Uh, well,
the reason is that you haven't
been a good guy yet. You know,
you haven't been giving the
broker other business, uh,
and you hear stories about IPO
is that did spectacularly well.
Uh, yeah, jumped 30% on the first day
and you say, Hey, I want that. Um,
but um,
it becomes sort of a game they're playing.
It's a little bit like
trying to get tickets to some
rare concert. Okay. I mean,
people will sometimes, or there's a,
someone coming to a toads who's, I don't,
I don't go there,
but if you know about someone who's
very famous is coming to toads, right?
And you have trouble getting tickets,
is that right?
Does anything like this happen here?
It happened somewhere anyway.
And so you might end up standing in line
for hours and the first time the ticket
office opens, right? And then it
sets up rumors going that, wow,
you know, this is a difficult
concert to get into. Uh,
and then people start trading the tickets
afterwards or someone out there asking
more money than it says on the ticket.
We have to understand that that whole
event was staged by an Impresario.
Right? So there's someone who responsible
for the reputation of this performer.
Okay.
And this guy says,
there's no way that our performance is
going to go in and perform to a half
empty house.
We've got to pack them in and we
want people lining up on the streets.
Cause it sense, it gives a sense of
excitement that this person is a star.
But you know this,
right?
The stars are managed and they're
not just spectacularly good singers.
They're,
the Impresario is critically important
in maintaining the career of a singer and
the [inaudible].
I was very concerned about appearances.
And so you don't want to charge a really
high price to get into toads because
then it would only be wealthy people
from the suburbs would becoming,
and it would destroy the whole
atmosphere of the place, right?
So you've got to charge
reasonably low price tickets. Uh,
and then a lot of people will
come flocking to you. Uh,
and then that would create the excitement.
The underwriters do the
same thing with Ipos.
So they under priced them typically,
and it creates this huge, uh,
excitement about, can I get
in on this IPO? Uh, and,
um, and that excitement
generates more business.
So, uh, and it also generates a
reputation for the underwriter.
People see the tombstone
and they know that this,
this IPO did extremely well.
It jumped up, you know,
a high amount in the first day and
people think this underwriter is really
something I want to get in and
other offerings of that underwriter.
And so the reputation of
the underwriter grows.
So it's really a reputation business
and these people know something about
investor psychology and uh,
you,
you might consider it some
kind of market manipulation,
but it's all perfectly legal because
the sec allows this kind of thing. But,
uh,
so anyway,
coming back to the problem that we're
having now is that I'm emphasizing that
investment bankers need reputation there.
Their whole business is
a reputation business.
And so when something
happens to bear Stearns,
it's critical for the whole industry.
And now when it's happening repeatedly
to various other banks, uh, it becomes a,
uh, a critical turning
point. Uh, so the market,
the stock market went up a lot yesterday
because of the encouraging news that
some of these investment banks were
able to raise more capital. Uh,
and it's an ongoing saga,
but it's all Kusamba that's
played out in terms of investment.
And so I find it difficult to predict
what's going to happen next. Uh,
it's very hard to know.
Um, right now, yes,
as of yesterday,
we had some encouraging news,
but this is something that we'll
just have to keep watching.
I think this will play out over a years.
This thing is not going
to be over tomorrow,
so we'll have more interesting things to
talk about later this semester. And, uh,
there'll be things to watch, uh, to
follow up on over the years. Okay.
So we're going to talk next period
about investment management.